le sauver djamena est arrivé dans un
contexte particulier c'est un contexte
où il y à une fronde en fait aussi bien
un hexagone que dans le ciel devant
l'engagement militaire de la france au
sahel et il était donc nécessaire pour
le président macron pour justifier le
maintien la continuation de cette
opération d'utiliser ces langages très
fort qui expliquerait si vous voulez en
termes de retours hic la nécessité de
répondre de manière très forte à des
ennemis qui sur le terrain de faire
continuer de signer la mort du maquereau
a insisté aussi sur les dégâts que ces
groupes font sur le terrain aussi bien
sur les civils il a insisté aussi sur
les pertes côté français donc je pense
que derrière cette retirer cette
rhétorique il y à la nécessité pour le
président français d'expliquer un
contexte qui nécessite une présence
forte de la france et une présence
régulière devant un ennemi qui fait des
dégâts aussi bien sur les amener du
design et du sahel que les communautés
aussi l'armée française